On the eleventh day of Christmas, we have
element number eleven, sodium. Not a
piece of sodium, a tile with sodium on it
and sodium is element number 11 and it
really is a tile, look on the back. It
was made by an Italian school girl
called Sofia who was brought here by
her father Leonardo plus a school friend
and other family members.
She's a real Periodic Videos fan and
she wanted to come for her birthday to
Nottingham and she made this tile for me
so I could put my mug on top of it and
the reason why she chose sodium is
because she saw in a video, our sodium
video, that I said that sodium was my
favorite element
- Holy crap
- Not because it explodes, but because my mother's first name, her Christian
name was Ina, I-N-A,
and as a little girl she used to call herself Na and my children used to call their
grandmother Na because of this, so every
time I see the symbol Na, N-A, I get
just a warm motherly feeling and Sophia liked this and made me a great tile. So I have
it on my desk and I brought it down here
specially for the eleventh day. So number eleven,
tile with sodium, two elements
osmium and thorium, periodic table handkerchief, charred beam from our carbon lab,
fan from a fan, element six carbon, glowing plectrum for guitar, four drinking vessels,
three chemical badges, two periodic table bed covers, and one piece of tartaric acid from a Swiss wine barrel.
Let's see what we have for day twelve!
...tiny droplets of metallic sodium
and as these droplets go through the air
some of them will react with the water vapor
in the air
and some will react with the oxygen in the air, and
there's a lot more oxygen than water...